head of xbox is feeling good about the
activision blizzard buyout while not as
certain about console exclusivity
meanwhile dead island 2 hands-on
coverage has found its way out in the
wild
phil spencer head of microsoft gaming
has recently commented on the proposed
acquisition of activision blizzard
saying that he feels pretty good about
it speaking to bloomberg he commented on
understanding the scrutiny of the
enormous deal now it's currently going
through the regulatory bodies of the
world with the first approval coming
from saudi arabia with the next ones
still being us in uk which are still
pending and due to the breadth of the
deal playstation raised concerns about
microsoft's exclusivity to some of the
ips the 69 billion dollar deal means
that microsoft will be acquiring
behemoth ipu's like call of duty
overwatch world of warcraft and candy
crush and if that already wasn't an
incredible feat phil spencer also
commented on his commitment to improve
sexism and discrimination that is
happening within activision blizzard's
offices
now of course with the recent
acquisition of microsoft obtaining
bethesda there has been a lot of debate
and conversation around console
exclusivity and what that means for
people who are fans of series is like
elder scrolls fallout and the upcoming
star field does that mean they're going
to have to shell out for xbox consoles
to play those games well phil spencer
also commented on that to bloomberg
saying that just broadly speaking we're
seeing less and less of it and that he
feels that naturally
it's going away with time now an
interesting thing to consider is the
recent uptick in sony exclusives we've
been seeing find their way onto pc with
the most recent being marvel spider-man
additionally death stranding another one
of playstation's exclusives to find its
way in pc was recently added to pc game
pass a microsoft service so
let that sink in
still while exclusivity concerns run
rampant the call of duty modern warfare
2 beta is going to be exclusive to
playstation for its first weekend so
take from that what you will
if you haven't heard the dead island
series ain't so dead because just
yesterday the long-awaited sequel was
finally shown at gamescom opening night
live and some lucky folk who were at the
convention in germany got to have some
hands-on time with it including
eurogamer and ign according to ign
writer matt purslow they got 20 minutes
of hands-on time as one of the game's
six playable characters in solo mode
however the final version of the game
will support up to three player co-op in
their preview they detail the game's
explicit fleshy gore and zombie
dismemberment including the way skin
chars if it's burned
in fact the game has its own in-game
system for procedurally generated zombie
gooey fleshy stuff called appropriately
flesh which stands for fully locational
evisceration system for humanoids now of
course we'll be able all of us will be
able to get hands on or hands in the gui
flush stuff sometime in early february
of 2023 when the game is expected to
launch
super smash bros creator is starting his
own youtube channel where he talks about
game design and it is appropriately
called masahiro sakurai on
creating games he detailed his vision to
create bite-sized videos about a range
of topics in video game design with an
emphasis on classic games he's also not
the only major developer to suddenly
just want to dip their toes into other
forms of content making in fact hideo
kojima took to gamescon yesterday to
announce that he's starting his own
podcast in september
alright folks that's it for today's news
thank you for coming here to gamespot to
check it out to be informed and stay
cool so you're in the know like all the
other cool gamers like you should be in
the know anyways we also have a bunch of
gamescom coverage happening all this
week so please stay here to check it out
including trailers gameplay clips and
all that jazz anyways i'm kurt till next
time see ya